what's going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder where we talk all
things marvel and mcu i'm your host
warren thompson and morbius the living
vampire is out today now the actual
release date is april 1st but of course
at your local theater you could probably
always see it a day or two before and if
you're here right now and you clicked on
this video you've probably seen it or
you simply kind of just don't care and
you want to know what's up with that
post credit scene and that's what we're
going to be talking about and big thank
you to booksu for sponsoring this video
more on them in a bit now i won't spoil
anything about the actual film morbius
in this video but we are going to be
talking about the two post credits
scenes because they set up some stuff in
the sony universe and whether or not you
think morbius is a terrible movie or a
good movie it does seem like sony has a
very specific direction they're moving
despite what happens in morbius and also
keep in mind morbius was filmed like
three years ago a lot has happened since
then it got delayed about two years and
there is a very apparent change to some
things that have happened in morbius
that are going to go on and affect
spider-man which is really the main
topic of this video yes it's a
post-credits team breakdown but really
what is being set up here is the future
of spider-man so again no spoilers about
morbius but i think most people know by
this point in time that there were a lot
of things changed last minute and these
things are important for the
post-credits scene and the future of
spider-man for example there was that
scene in the trailer that had morbius
walking away down an alley there was a
picture of spider-man on the side that
said murderer over it they took that out
of the movie that's not in the film also
michael keaton's vulture who was also a
very exciting part of some of the
trailers that we saw he wasn't in the
film either and if you're wondering if
this is actually the same adrian tombs
from spider-man homecoming yes it is
because the director came out on twitter
in an interview and asked me anything
with cinemablend and he confirmed it's
true he confirmed this is the same
vulture in adrian tombs from the
homecoming universe so why did they take
him out why did they take spider-man off
of the wall in that shot from morbius
well it becomes very clear when you see
the post-credits scene the first
post-credits scene shows us a shot of
the city just as a huge purple rift
appears in the sky which of course is
the same purple rift from spider-man no
way home of doctor strange doing his
spell this of course was the characters
coming in from other universes into the
main mcu but it seems to work backwards
for adrian tombs here because we then
cut to the inside of an empty prison
cell which adrian tombs or vulture
appears from thin air inside of it he
checks out himself in the mirror because
he looks a little bit different than
before but overall is fine and since in
this universe he hasn't committed any
crimes he gets released so doctor
strange's spell in spider-man no way
home managed to bring some characters
into the mcu from other universes but it
appears that for adrian tomb vulture it
actually took him out of the mcu and
brought him into the sony universe which
is very interesting and makes you
question a lot of things until the next
post-credit scene comes up and it offers
a little bit of clarity of what sony's
plan is the second post-credit scene we
actually see morbius meeting up with
vulture who is now in his vulture
high-tech gear which if you noticed when
you watch this does actually look a
little bit different than the one that
he had in homecoming and the director
daniel espinosa did confirm that it is
indeed a little bit different but this
actually doesn't make sense because this
universe shouldn't actually contain the
disregarded alien technology that adrian
tomb salvages to make his suit but we're
gonna kind of overlook that for now but
vulture suggests to morbius that they
team up to do some good and he implies
that they're going after spider-man for
some reason and morbius agrees and he
finds the idea intriguing now what's
interesting is that the last time we saw
vulture he was kind of defending
spider-man and refused to give up his
identity as peter parker because he knew
who he was but of course i don't think
anybody believes that his intentions are
good and it now seems like he's going
after spider-man for some reason but
basically what we are seeing here right
now is the formation of the sinister six
the very beginning of it a true sinister
six and the first two members of the
sinister six are morbius and vulture but
the big question here is who are going
to be the other members of the sinister
six and which spider-man is the
spider-man that is in this sony universe
not the mcu that they're talking about
going after and if michael keaton's
vulture says that he wants to do some
good why are they going after spider-man
could spider-man be bad in their
universe remember there was that picture
originally on the wall that said
murderer over it so spider-man might not
actually be seen as a good guy in this
universe right now and i personally
think and hope that this spider-man is
andrew garfield so let's talk about that
but first let me tell you about my
friends over at boksu buksu is a monthly
subscription service that delivers
premium japanese snacks and t-pairings
straight from japan to your door each
booksuit box features a new theme
providing a gourmet journey through
japan every month and this month's theme
is sakura and as you can see it is
packed with all sorts of limited edition
cherry blossom themed snacks every year
japanese cherry blossoms bloom all
across japan and people celebrate by
getting together under the trees for
hanami or flower viewing and they have
picnics together now i've been trying to
go to japan for the past few years but
the pandemic made that really hard so
this box is the perfect way to
experience sakura season from home this
booklet even tells you exactly what
everything is and where it comes from in
japan so this is a sakura sweet cookie
from shizuoka japan
mmm that has a amazing sakura flavor so
if you want to have your own sakura
celebration and support the channel be
sure to click the link in the
description down below and use my code
cosmic for 15 off your order so a new
spider-man is in this universe it's not
tom holland because marvel and sony made
that very clear with the post-credit of
spider-man no way home where we saw a
piece of the venom symbiote be left
behind in the mcu actual venom that we
know from the sony universe and tom
hardy's eddie brock went back to the
sony spider-man universe which was a
very definitive statement by sony in
marvel studios hey tom hardy's venom is
going to fight a spider-man that is not
tom holland spider-man because tom hardy
has teased that venom 3 is going to be
versus spider-man and now tom holland's
peter parker is going to be going up
against venom but it's not going to be
tom hardy's venom and eddie brock it's
going to be a new person that this venom
symbiote attaches to so who is the new
spider-man in the sony universe well
spider-man no way home came out and
andrew garfield spider-man got a major
redemption in this film and not only did
his character get redemption him saving
mj because he couldn't save gwen but he
got redemption as well because he never
got his third amazing spider-man film
and his films got a lot of hate but now
he's getting a lot of love and we even
have a make tasm 3 petition going around
right now and in fact the sony twitter
team said that they have acknowledged
that petition and that hashtag but
they're not the ones that make the movie
but they're still sony so sony of course
knows what's happening here then after
no way home came out insider started to
talk stating that sony wants andrew
garfield to come back and play more
roles they also would like toby to cameo
and some other things as well and if you
didn't know the director recently came
out and said that a new spider-man
should be announced from sony soon in
that ask me anything with cinemablend on
twitter they asked is there a spider-man
in venom's universe in which daniel
espinoza replied of course and the next
question was okay so which spider-man
exists in venom's universe and i should
add that they did confirm that venom's
universe is morbius's universe but
daniel espinoza replied saying it is my
understanding that audiences will
discover the answer soon so it looks
like sony does indeed have a plan
involving spider-man and the sinister
six in fact the last question of the ask
me anything was is vulture and morbius
setting up for a sinister six movie in
which he replied well he is recruiting
teammates and he has enticed one already
so it sure looks like a start so that is
sony's plan they're going to do a
spider-man sinister six movie with a new
spider-man that apparently is going to
be announced pretty soon and since they
have pretty much drawn the line and
stated tom holland is indeed the mcu
spider-man and won't be in their
spider-man universe over at sony we are
indeed getting a new spider-man who i
think and hope will be andrew garfield
because that just makes the most sense
he's never fought venom before and since
tom holland spider-man is fighting a
different venom and toby maguire
spider-man has fought venom already it
would make sense for andrew garfield to
be the main spider-man of this universe
plus not to mention venom is most likely
going to be the third member of the
sinister six in the sony universe we
also have a craven the hunter movie that
is going to be coming up as well i'm
assuming a post-credits scene for that
movie is going to involve him joining
the sinister six so there's four members
right there and so far i'm actually
really liking these four members going
up against andrew garfield spider-man i
actually think that if they do it right
it'll be a pretty good movie my only
concern is that andrew garfield just had
his redemption and then they'll make a
bad movie after this i really don't want
that to happen i really think they'll be
aware of that though and make sure it
doesn't happen but that is what the
morbius post-credit scenes are setting
up a new spider-man and a sinister six
to go up against spider-man so let me
know what you think about sony's plans
in the comments down below did you watch
morbius if so did you like it or not be
sure to let me know don't forget to like
the video and subscribe so you can stay
up to date on all things relating to
marvel and the mcu for live updates you
can follow me on instagram and twitter
and as always thank you all so much for
watching woof
you